-Welcome back.
I'm hanging out with Colson
Baker, a.k.a. Machine Gun Kelly.
His new movie, "Good Mourning,"
is in theaters
and on demand now.
And his album
"Mainstream Sellout"
is also out now.
Colson, I wanted to try
something fun with you.
I thought we could act out
a dramatic scene together, okay?
But first we have to
fill in the blanks.
It is time for
"Mad Lib Theater."
Here we go.
♪ Mad Lib Theater ♪
♪ Ah-ah, yeah! ♪
-Alright.
So here's how this works.
I'm gonna ask you for some
silly words -- nouns, verbs,
adjectives, et cetera --
and they'll all be written
onto our cue cards here,
as we're doing this.
And then we're gonna act out
a dramatic Mad Libs scene.
Are you ready for this?
-Thank God
I went to the fourth grade.
-Okay. Here we go.
I want a noun --
-Nouns, adjectives...
-Yes. I want a noun
that begins with a C.
-Koala.
Uh -- Uh, wait. Computer.
-Computer. Good.
Computer's good.
Adjective.
-Stinky.
-Type of bug.
-Caterpillar.
-Animal.
-Koala. Koala!
-Koala. Okay, good. Yeah.
[ Applause ]
They got your back.
A chain restaurant.
-Chipotle. I used to work there.
-Chipotle?
-Yeah.
-Noun.
-Baby.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Baby. Okay.
-Baby.
-A kitchen appliance.
-Spatula.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that you're --
you're so confident on spatula.
That was the one, you're like,
"Oh, no, no, yeah.
Spatula, of course."
A plural noun.
-Fungi.
[ Laughter ]
Right?
-Wow. That's next-level.
That's next --
That's next-level.
Fungi.
Another animal.
-Platypus.
One of the Seven Dwarves.
-Oh, I never watched that movie.
-Sleepy!
-Smokey. What?
-Smokey.
-Uh, what?
-Sleepy. Sleepy.
-No, no, I'm writing
down Smokey because --
Celebrity name.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Benedict Cumberbatch.
[ Laughter ]
Name me a number.
-Just eleven -- eleven --
-Eleven tousand.
-Tousand, with a T-O-U.
Eleven tousand.
-Eleven tousand.
-Yes.
-Type of profession.
-Genie.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! Speed round. Here we go.
Another plural noun.
-Moose.
-Moose. Mooses?
What?
-Moose. What is going on?
[ Laughter ]
Uh, okay. Body part.
Watch it.
-Yeah. Elbow.
-Elbow!
-What?
-Wow. That was weird.
Phrase that you would say
if you bumped
into Leonardo DiCaprio
on the street.
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Fingers snapping ]
-"You --
Why did you let go, Jack?
You should have
stayed on the door.
You should've got on the door."
"Why did you let go, Jack?
There was room
for you on the door."
-Alright.
"Why did you let go, Jack?"
Another noun.
-You do this one.
-Burrito.
-Type of drink.
-Bloody Mary.
Another celebrity.
-Waka Flocka Flame.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Flocka Flame.
Verb ending in I-N-G.
-Clenching.
-Clenching?
-I'm -- I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
-This is fun doing Mad Libs
with you.
What you'd shout if you sat down
in a seat that's wet.
-"Aah."
-A high pitched "aah"?
First concert you ever attended.
-Oh. Backstreet Boys. What's up?
-Wow. Backstreet boys.
A professional athlete.
-Tiger Woods!
-Tom Brady.
-Alright. Tom Brady. Tom Brady.
Another verb ending in I-N-G.
-Crying.
Yes, good. Crying.
Two words that rhyme.
-Garage, Minaj.
-Wow. Garage, Minaj.
A long, silly word.
-Iridocyclitis!
-What?!
-Is that a disease?
-Is that an actual --
Yeah. What is that?
-"Iri-dopta--dacly--"
I'm happy the edibles
are kicking in.
This is a...
-"Iridocyclitis."
-Yeah, we --
-Iridocyclitis. Yeah, of course.
Alright, now, we've filled out
the words for our scene.
Good luck to our cue card.
So sorry, Roman.
Are you ready
to perform our scene?
-I don't know now.
-Let's go. Let's do this.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Rumbling ]
♪♪
-Am I green?
-No, yeah, you're green.
Yeah. You're green. I'm red.
Computer Man!
What are you doing here?!
-Oh, hello, Captain Stinky.
-Please call me by my nickname,
Mr. Caterpillar.
-I'm here for the same reason
you are here --
to rescue the koala stuck
on the roof of this Chipotle.
-I knew
there was trouble tonight
when I saw my signal
in the sky --
a light projected
in the shape of a...baby.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, using our powers,
this rescue should be simple.
I'm faster
than a speeding spatula,
and everything I touch
turns to fungi.
-Impressive.
I have the agility
of a platypus.
And when I get really smokey,
I turn into
Benedict Cumberbatch.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
I must tell you,
my back story is complicated.
When I was eleven tousand
years old, I was...
I was once bitten by a genie.
[ Laughter ]
And ever since, I've been able
to emanate mooses from my elbow.
-Why did you let go, Jack?
-I know.
It's amazing, but with great
power comes great burrito.
[ Laughter ]
-Your story
reminds me of my own.
I became a superhero
after I fell into a tub
of radioactive bloody Mary.
But listen.
We must complete this rescue.
Because there's something
you don't know.
In the trapped koala's collar,
there's a USB drive
that contains images of
Waka Flocka Flame clenching...
[ Laughter ]
Clenching his...
-Aah.
-No, no.
His fist, his fist, his fist.
-Yes.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And as a warning,
I do have one weakness.
-What is it?
-Backstreet Boys.
-That's okay.
Just remember what
Professor Tom Brady told us.
He said if we're ever
in a situation like this,
you press this button,
and we will both
immediately start crying.
Here we go.
[ Both fake crying ]
It's working!
Our crying is causing
the koala to be saved!
-Garage, Minaj! We did it!
-Yes, let's high-five
and say the secret
superhero catch phrase
on "three."
One, two, three.
Uh...
-Iri-dira-calaptus.
-[ Stammering ]
-Dude!
-Yeah!
-And scene!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks...
My thanks to Colson Baker,
a.k.a. Machine Gun Kelly.